ثلاث دول عربيه من اكثر الدول اصابه
بالسكري ومنهم للاسف بلدك انت يا عادل
الكويت مستويات السمنه والسكر مرتفع جدا
للاسف عندنا ايضا في باكستان هي المرتبه
الاولى 31% تقريبا من السكان هذا رقم كبير
ومغول فيه بالكويت اكيد المرتبه الثانيه
كانت بحدود 25
[موسيقى]
بالمئه ونارو وهي جزيره صغيره في المحيط
الهادي حلت ثالثه بحوالي
24% ايضا كاليدونيا الجديده او كاليدونيا
الجديده كما تسمى هي الرابعه
23.40% عنا ايضا جزر ماريانا الشماليه وهي
تاتي في المرتبه الخامسه جزر مارشل
بنسبه 23% يعني الكثير من الجزر على ما
يبدو انطلق عليها الكلام
تاتي في المرتبه طبعا السابع مصر في
المرتبه الثامنه بنسبه 21% يعني في اكثر
من عشرين مليون شخص في مصر يعانون من
السكري جزر سليمان تاتي في المرتبه
التاسعه بنسبه 20%
في المرتبه العاشره لدينا قطر مشاهدينا
بنسبه 19.5
طبعا بس نوضح بانه ترى على فكره يعني حتى
لو هي نسبه وتناسب قد يكون عدد السكان 3
مليون ولكن نسبه المصابين 25% منهم عاليه
جدا بينما مصر مثلا 100 مليون عشرين
بالمئه فقط منهم مصابين فبالتالي
هو اللافت في الموضوع بانه السكر اصلا
قديش في دعوات هلا للاقلاع عن السكر وقف
السكر بشكل كامل مع انه احنا بنحكي عن
المحليات
ويعني في بكون في نوع من انواع المعجزه
اللي بتحصل بالجسم مجرد ما الانسان يوقف
سكر تخيل يعني لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات